Film Courage: Chad, we have a quote here
from someone, which is an unlikely quote
regarding acting.
It’s from David Bowie.
I just read it the other day and I found it
interesting.
The quote said “As You Get Older Questions
Come Down to About Two or Three Things:
How long and what do I do with the time that
I have left?”
And the reason this quote stuck out to me
is that I’m thinking about it in my own
life and I was wondering for you, do this
bring up anything interesting?
Just because life changes after the 20’s
and…
Chad Lindberg: Yeah…I mean I just turned
40 and so that question definitely looms.
It’s like how much longer?
How am I going to go?
And what more do I have to do here?
There’s a lot to do.
I feel like 40 is the new 20.
Maybe?
I don’t know [laughs]?
It makes me reflect on all of my time that
I’ve spent in Los Angeles and pursuing an
acting career.
And I look back and I’m like “Thank, God!”
because when you’re young you don’t realize
what you’re getting into, you know?
And I kind of had my blinders on and I’m
like Nothing is Going to Get Here [gestures
in front of his eyes].
I am going to do it.
And I’m very lucky that it happened because
it doesn’t happen for a lot of people.
So 22 years in, I’m like [exhales a sigh
of relief].
But…it’s still just as hard as it was.
Film Courage: O.k.
Well, first off you are an incredibly young
40, so you have this on your side.
Chad Lindberg: Thank you!
Film Courage: But now do you think maybe
there will be new roles, maybe not Jesse [in
FAST AND FURIOUS] or maybe Jesse reinvented?
There is a whole new thing open to you as
a 40-year-old male where you could still pass
for way younger but…
Chad Lindberg: Yeah…well I appreciate
that.
I can’t do high school anymore [laughs].
I’m pushing college age but it definitely
worked for me when I was younger.
I played…you know, I was age 20 playing
a 15 year old.
So now I can still play thirties but it definitely
lends me to do more interesting roles I think
because I have grown into myself, I know who
I am, I’m much more confident in who I am.
You know, when you are in the late twenties
to early thirties, I kind of squandered a
bit because I’m like, “Well I don’t
really fit here and I don’t really fit here.”
So now that I’ve come into my forties I
feel very confident about where I am going.
Film Courage: Where did you think that you
didn’t fit in?
That’s interesting.
Because I don’t see you that way….I could
see you fitting into so many roles.
Chad Lindberg: Well, I wasn’t quite a
man [laughs] as funny as that sounds.
I’m in my early thirties were a really
tough time in this business because I started
out by getting big roles in this business
right away.
I mean I started working off my first audition
I booked and my career started out kind of
like here.
And as I was age thirty I kind of had to backtrack
a little bit and sort out what a lot of actors
go through in the beginning of their careers.
Trying to get the hustle and so had to step
back a little bit and reassess everything.
So I wasn’t quite an older guy to play this
role and I wasn’t quite young enough.
Interesting enough in my early thirties it
was an awkward stage for me as weird as that
is.
Question for the viewers: What are your thoughts
on how age impacts an actor’s career?